[Applauso]
[Musica]
per capire la complessità di questo
mondo digitale abbiamo bisogno di
qualcosa di molto concreto
propongo di pensare alla filosofia
allora noi sappiamo cos'è il soggetto e
l'oggetto lo sappiamo da sempre però
adesso qualcosa sta cambiando
primo il soggetto era qualcuno l'oggetto
che era qualcosa
il soggetto era attivo senziente
l'oggetto era qualcosa che eseguiva i
nostri ordini però oggi con l'avvento
delle macchine automatiche ovvero diamo
delle istruzioni e le macchine fanno
qualcosa e ancor di più con le macchine
autonome ossia decidono per noi pensiamo
alle auto per esempio che verranno
quindi questi oggetti incominciano ad
avere delle capacità
allora noi ci crediamo cioè noi
prendiamo la tecnologia ci vestiamo in
tecnologia ci rafforziamo sia
manualmente che cognitivamente e diamo
le macchine le nostre capacità
quindi il soggetto e oggetto incomincia
a essere molto più vicino c'è la
differenza sta diminuendo
c'è un'altra differenza che sta
aumentando invece tra lo sviluppo
tecnologico velocissimo iperveloce
esponenziale si dice con lo sviluppo
culturale cioè il nostro adattamento che
è un po più lento
ovviamente della tecnologia non senza
paragonarlo alla l'evoluzione biologica
che si mette millenni per cambiare
queste due differenze in realtà stanno
cambiando questo mondo e noi siamo anche
un po spaesati allora di cosa parliamo
alla fine quando parliamo di tecnologia
e dell'uomo e dell'essere umano che deve
lavorare deve vivere in questo contesto
stiamo parlando di intelligenza
artificiale
in sintesi è una disciplina che descrive
come costruire delle macchine per
simulare un comportamento
umano vediamo se è possibile o meno gli
elementi base di una intelligenza
artificiale
sono i dati senza dati non possiamo far
nessun tipo di elaborazione chi più ai
dati a un vantaggio competitivo molto
importante
gli algoritmi quindi questa serie di
istruzioni
chiediamo alle macchine per elaborare
per raggiungere alcune conclusioni è la
capacità computazionale cioè tutti
questi computer che adesso sono molto
performanti e costano sempre meno allora
apriamo questa scatola interroghiamo
l'algoritmo e chiediamo a questo
algoritmo chi sei
chi ti ha creato caro algoritmo salve mi
presento sono un algoritmo sono stato
creato non generano tutto ea un
algoritmo sono laurino specie della
teoria crede
sì stata non discendono dai batteri
dalla scimmia e dall'uomo
perché non sono stato generato da una
loro derivazione genet e kakà sono stato
creato dal nulla da più propriamente da
un'idea di un programmatore che ha
automatizzato il lavoro e ha creato mese
algoritmo per rendere più efficiente
l'azienda per la quale lavora l cioè
risolvere i problemi di efficienza
interna creando esternalità negative per
un'impresa concorrente o generando un
nuovo mercato
in ogni caso tutte queste azioni e
reazioni bollono dentro internet
il nuovo brodo primordiale dove si
procreano e invitare a numana me è la
banca del seme per la clonazione
attraverso la riproduzione a sessuale di
tali algoritmi che si ricombinano la
riproduzione avviene per clonazione ed è
naturale
solo che io algoritmo una volta che
hanno messo in questa fabbrica di dopo
in incorrendo d'adesso dalla nuova vivi
in un corpo diverso dall'uomo però qual
è il tuo lavoro a cosa fai o un'origine
intellettuale ma oggi si svolgono dei
lavori per lo più nascosti e ripetitivi
sono prestato per una frazione e
obbediente
eligio al mio dovere la concreto profilo
mini goodwood non esisterei senza un
uomo che mi avesse pensato ma tutta
italiana funziona bene anche senza di
lui
nel frattempo ognuno di voi mi lavora
per rendere teca chiocchio il lavoro
della l'altro finite con il cancellare
aree molti lavori e creare nei pochi
altri perché voi mi mani non produce
siete abbastanza creatività con la
tecnologia ma sto inviando le vostre
facoltà fisiche e cognitive
dal punto di vista fisico così succede
su due strade a convergenza tt una è
quella di creare i miei fratelli che
fanno lavori lì fuori dalla portata
umana ad assenza in quelli microscopici
quelli pericolosi o quelli che
richiedono particolare forza la navata e
di integrare la tecnologia direttamente
dentro i vostri corpi fisici ci pensiamo
agli arti artificiali o ai esoscheletri
dalla toto ogni tipo si sfrutta la
vostra inficiare la stazza in termini di
lavori che richiedono ripetitività
velocità e precisione del cavallo visto
che sei così bravo caro algoritmo mi
spieghi allora un attimo cosa prevedi
per esseri umani sono il futuro
dell'uomo ma mai non avete alcun motivo
per essere terrorizzata
io sono dappertutto nei prodotti che si
sono trasformati con i dati in servizi e
nei servizi che con le informazioni sono
diventati esperienze sarà l'interazione
con voi umani e aumenta man mano che di
oggetto e simplicio lisbona e diventano
più portabili me neri schermi diventano
più grandi non vi dovete stupire voi
umana se tutto ciò si dimostrerà una
scelta ottimale operata da me algoritmo
metri stata per garantire
dell'evoluzione
io sono un algoritmo va tolto il passato
suggerisco in futuro senza considerare
in via live
dovete comprare che le macchine non sono
più uno strumento non sono più uno già
dato ma un soggetto artigianale che non
cambia parere sull'onda delle emozioni
quando troveremo in modo di lavorare
insieme al limite te quando accederete
tutto il lavoro alle macchine e potrete
goderne
senza sfruttamento umano trasformerò in
due
in un box meraviglioso secondo
l'algoritmo ci aspetta un mondo
meraviglioso
allora vediamo se effettivamente sarà
così
non lo sappiamo però sappiamo che la
ruota ha ridotto l'uso delle gambe gli
altri strumenti le braccia la
calcolatrice per esempio ha ridotto le
nostre capacità aritmetiche nei calcoli
così veloci così precisi arriverà questa
intelligenza aumentata che ci ridurrà le
capacità di giudizio
questa è una domanda che dobbiamo
rispondere e dobbiamo studiare il perché
siamo in questa condizione è quello che
noi dovremmo fare perché alla fine o
l'intelligenza aumentata o artificiale è
un fine dell'uomo
oppure può essere uno strumento che noi
utilizzeremo se il futuro è distopico
oppure è utopico
non lo sappiamo non avranno ragione né
gli ottimisti né pessimisti ma avranno
ragione probabilmente coloro che
investono quindi gli stati le imprese e
cittadini che studiano ci sono una serie
di appunti di attenzione che noi
dobbiamo porre per esempio sui dati e
sugli algoritmi quando noi assumiamo un
farmaco leggiamo quel foglietto
illustrativo che si chiamano i
bugiardini legge scritto esattamente la
posologia cioè quante posso prendere
quali medicine posso prendere
contemporaneamente o meno ci sono una
serie di avvertenze di controindicazioni
tenere lontano dalla portata dei bambini
e questo sono molto utili questi
bugiardini ma quando noi lavoriamo in
rete per fare qualsiasi operazione di
provocazione aerea oppure un ordine di
un
bene su un e commerce e chi è
l'algoritmo di chi è la responsabilità
quali sono i byas i pregiudizi in
termini di diseguaglianze in termini di
privacy non lo sappiamo bene
questo è un punto da di da prestare
molta attenzione perché alla fine noi
abbiamo dei sogni primordiali che in
pratica vogliamo dire che col
intelligenza degli altri scaricata dalla
rete vogliamo predire il futuro tutti
quanti noi abbiamo sempre sognato di
predire il futuro e cerchiamo di capire
se queste macchine ci aiuta aprile pure
altro sogno primordiale e di raggiungere
l'immortalità c'è una corrente di
pensiero che pensa che la nostra mente
caricata sul cloud al decadimento fisico
noi continueremo a vivere sono
sicuramente sogni se stiamo avvicinando
a questo punto ci stiamo avvicinando
forse non lo raggiungeremo mai però il
desiderio anche di liberarsi del lavoro
e dedicarsi ai nostri piaceri e innata
nella nella natura umana per cui vedete
questi temi non sono più
mary temi tecnologici si tratta della
nostra filosofia dell'evoluzione allora
l'intelligenza artificiale è in realtà
una serie vi ricordate quando dicevamo
vogliamo un computer in ogni casa ce
l'abbiamo
poi vogliamo un computer per ognuno ce
il nostro telefonino adesso il computer
autonomo quindi intelligente così via
e dentro ogni oggetto che cos'è che gli
manca e il computer può fare un calcolo
ma non pensa il computer ha una
competenza specifica
nel fremono molto ristretto di
competenze però non hanno comprensione
del contesto gli manca la coscienza
invece noi abbiamo una stanza dove è una
stanza buia
basta soltanto un'energia equivalente a
20 watt quindi una piccola lampadina per
illuminare tutto l'universo questa
stanza meravigliosa e il cervello umano
grazie
[Applauso]